WAS FOUND AT MAR-A-LAGO.
JAKE.
>> KATELYN POLANTZ, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
JOINING US TO DISCUSS IS ELIE
HONIG, FORMER U.S. ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY.
DO YOU THINK THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS DOING THE RIGHT
THING, TRYING TO BLOCK RELEASE
OF THIS AFFIDAVIT?
>> WELL, JAKE, I'M NOT AT ALL
SURPRISED DOJ IS RESISTING THIS.
THIS AFFIDAVIT, SO PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND, IS THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT DOCUMENT IN THIS WHOLE
CASE.
THIS IS THE DOCUMENT WHERE
PROSECUTORS HAVE TO LAY OUT IN
DETAIL IN NARRATIVE FASHION WHAT
THEIR PROBABLE CAUSE IS TO
BELIEVE THAT THE CRIMES WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE PRIOR DOCUMENTS WERE
COMMITTED AND THAT THERE WOULD
BE EVIDENCE AT MAR-A-LAGO.
AND THEN THEY BRING THIS
DOCUMENT OVER TO A JUDGE WHO HAS
TO REVIEW IT, AND WE KNOW IN
THIS CASE DID AGREE IT MADE OUT
PROBABLE CAUSE.
JUST FOR A SENSE OF CONTEXT, THE
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE UNSEALED ON
FRIDAY, THEY TOTAL SEVEN PAGES.
THIS AFFIDAVIT TYPICALLY WILL BE
DOZENS OF PAGES, 50 PAGES, I
HAVE SEEN 100-PLUS PAGE
AFFIDAVITS.
THERE'S ONLY TWO GROUPS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE THIS DOCUMENT.
PROSECUTORS AND THE JUDGE.
DONALD TRUMP DOES NOT HAVE IT,
WE DON'T HAVE IT IN THE PUBLIC.
I'M NOT SURPRISED DOJ IS
RESISTING BECAUSE TO REVEAL THIS
DOCUMENT WOULD SIMPLY REVEAL THE
ENTIRE ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
>> THERE WAS SPECULATION THAT
PERHAPS DOJ WAS JUST GOING TO --
THIS WAS JUST ABOUT DOCUMENT
RETRIEVAL.
THEY ISSUED A SUBPOENA, TRIED TO
GET THESE DOCUMENTS.
THEY WENT IN THERE, GOT THE
DOCUMENTS.
THEY HAD BEEN ATTEMPTING TO DO
SO IN A FRIENDLY FASHION, BUT
THAT DIDN'T WORK.
NOW THEY HAVE THEM BACK.
BUT THIS REFUSAL TO DISCLOSE THE
AFFIDAVIT AND THE LANGUAGE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT USES TALKING
ABOUT CONTINUED INVESTIGATION,
WITNESSES, GRAND JURY, THIS
SUGGESTS THERE ARE CRIMINAL
CHARGES BEING BROUGHT AND IT'S
NOT JUST A QUESTION OF TRYING TO
GET THESE DOCUMENTS BACK.
>> YEAH, THIS FILING DOES
CONFIRM THAT THERE'S AN ONGOING
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, AND
REALLY, WE KNEW THAT FROM THE
START BECAUSE YOU CANNOT GET A
SEARCH WARRANT BY JUST SAYING TO
A JUDGE, HEY, JUDGE, THERE'S
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
WE REALLY WANT TO GET IT BACK.
IN ORDER TO GET A SEARCH
WARRANT, AS A MATTER OF LAW, YOU
HAVE TO ESTABLISH PROBABLE CAUSE
THAT AT LEAST ONE SPECIFIC
FEDERAL CRIME WAS COMMITTED.
WE NOW KNOW WHAT THE FEDERAL
CRIMES WERE, ESPIONAGE ACT,
DESTRUCTION OF DOCUMENTS, AND
OBSTRUCTION, BUT YES, THIS HAS
BEEN AND REMAINS AN ONGOING
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
>> IS THERE A RISK THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, WHICH A LOT
OF DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ARE
SAYING NEEDS TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THIS
UNPRECEDENTED RAID ON
MAR-A-LAGO, IS THERE A RISK THAT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT BY TRYING
TO BLOCK THE RELEASE OF THIS
AFFIDAVIT LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE
TRYING TO BE TOO SECRETIVE?
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND IT'S SORT OF
A NO-WIN SITUATION FOR DOJ.
BY THE BOOK AS A DOJ PROSECUTOR,
IT'S AN EASY CALL.
YOU FIGHT THIS.
YOU DON'T OPEN UP AFFIDAVITS.
YOU DON'T REVEAL ONGOING
INVESTIGATIONS, BUT PROSECUTORS
ALSO HAVE TO LIVER IN REALITY.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SEPARATE
POLITICS AND LAW HERE.
I THINK THE REALITY IS IT WILL
LOOK LIKE THERE'S A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY AND WE'RE HEARING
FOR CALLS FOR MORE TRANSPARENCY
FROM BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
>> IS AN AFFIDAVIT SOMETHING THE
TRUMP TEAM WOULD WANT TO BE MADE
PUBLIC FOR ANY REASON?
>> A GREAT QUESTION.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY DOJ DOES
NOT REVEAL THESE AFFIDAVITS IS
BECAUSE YOU'RE PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF THE INNOCENT, THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE, THE
RIGHTS OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT
BEEN ACCUSED.
AND JUST SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND,
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THIS DOCUMENT,
BUT IT WOULD LAY OUT IN DETAIL
THE PROBABLE CAUSE DOJ USED TO
GET THE SEARCH WARRANT.
IT WOULD LAY OUT PROBABLE CAUSE
THAT CRIMES WERE COMMITTED.
I DON'T KNOW THAT DONALD TRUMP
AND HIS SUPPORTERS WOULD WANT
THAT TO BE OUT THERE IN THE
PUBLIC.
>> LET'S TURN TO HAD NEWS THAT
RUDY GIULIANI, TRUMP'S FORMER
ATTORNEY, HAS BEEN INFORMED HE'S
A TARGET IN THE FULTON COUNTY,
GEORGIA, DISTRICT ATTORNEY
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
TEAM'S EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE
2020 ELECTION IN GEORGIA.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN PRECISELY
THAT GIULIANI HAS BEEN TOLD HE'S
A TARGET?
>> SHORT OF BEING TOLD YOU HAVE
BEEN INDICTED, THAT'S ABOUT THE
WORST NEWS YOU CAN GET.
GENERALLY SPEAKING IN ANY
INVESTIGATION, PROSECUTORS
SEPARATE PEOPLE INTO THREE
CATEGORIES.
WITNESSES HAO HAVE DONE NOTHING
WRONG, SUBJECTS WHO MAYBE ARE IN
THE GRAY AREA, AND THEN A
TARGET.
TYPICALLY WHAT THAT MEANS IS
THIS IS A PERSON WHO IS LIKELY
TO BE INDICTED.
NOW, IT'S WORTH NOTING THE
FULTON COUNTY D.A. HAS BEEN VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN THE USE OF THIS
TARGET LANGUAGE.
SHE HAS NOT ONLY NOTIFIED RUDY
GIULIANI BUT AT LEAST 17 OTHER
PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE TARGETS.
NONE OF THEM HAVE BEEN INDICTED
YET, BUT IT'S STILL FAIRLY EARLY
AND THAT COULD CHANGE SOMETIME
SOON.
>> TODAY A FEDERAL JUDGE RULED
REPUBLICAN SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM HAS TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THAT SAME GRAND JURY IN FULTON
COUNTY, GEORGIA.
GRAHAM'S LAWYERS CAN APPEAL.
DO YOU THINK HE'LL APPEAL?
>> HE HAS A SHOT.
IT'S BASED ON THE SPEECH AND
DEBATE CLAUSE, WHICH BASICALLY
SAYS SITTING MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
CANNOT BE FORCED TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ELSEWHERE.
AND LINDSEY GRAHAM'S ARGUMENT IS
THIS DOES RELATE TO MY
LEGISLATIVE DUTIES.
THE DISTRICT COURT JUDGE
REJECTED THAT, BUT HIS NEXT STEP
IS TO APPEAL.
HE'S GOING TO THE 11th CIRCUIT
COURT OF APPEALS WHICH IS SEEN
AS THE SECOND OR THIRD MOST
CONSERVATIVE OF THE 13 FEDERAL
COURTS OF APPEALS, JAKE.
>> FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
CLAIMING THAT THE FBI, QUOTE,
TOOK BOXES OF PRIVILEGED
ATTORNEY/CLIENT TERM AND ALSO
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGED MATERIAL,
UNQUOTE.
COULD TRUMP TRY TO GO TO COURT
TO BLOCK THIS ENTIRE PROCESS ON
THOSE GROUNDS?
>> SO, USUALLY, PROCEDURALLY A
PERSON CANNOT CHALLENGE A SEARCH
WARRANT UNTIL AFTER HE'S BEEN
CHARGED AND PROSECUTORS TRY TO
USE THAT EVIDENCE AGAINST HIM.
DONALD TRUMP COULD TRY TO FILE A
MOTION HERE.
I THINK HE WOULD LOSE BOTH
PROCEDURALLY, I THINK A JUDGE
WOULD